meurtrier et dévastateur brutale les
adjectifs ne manquent pas pour décrire
ce conflit qui n'en finit plus de caen
majeur s'opposent depuis plus d'un an le
tplf tigréens et les forces
gouvernementales
le front de libération du peuple du
tigré est un ancien vous vous rendrez
bellion né dans les années 70 pour
défendre les intérêts de la population
tigréenne dans le nord du pays face à
l'ethnie dominante les amharas le
mouvement se transforme peu à peu en
parti politique et accède au pouvoir au
début des années 90 pendant trente ans
il dirige le pays jusqu'à l'accession au
pouvoir dabi ahmed en 2018 le tplf
refuse de se soumettre au pouvoir
central et se replient alors sur le
tigre et c'est de là que par le conflit
addis adeba envoie ses troupes pour
arrêter les leaders du tplf et reprendre
le contrôle de cette région en réponse
une milice armée est alors créé les
forces de défense du tigre et le 4
novembre 2020 le premier ministre
éthiopien lance une opération militaire
contre ses autorités régionales il les
accuse d'avoir orchestré des attaques
sur deux bases de l'armée fédérale nos
forces de défense nationales ont été
attaqué de dos ce soir alors qu'elle
gardait un oeil sur le côté pour
défendre la nation les forces qui ont
trahi l'ethiopie ont attaqué les troupes
des forces de défense alors qu'elle
dormait au camp et dans la ville de
mekele cet acte honteux sera évité une
fois pour toutes grâce aux efforts
conjoints du peuple éthiopien et du
ministère de la défense en trois
semaines de combats acharnés les forces
gouvernementales parviennent à prendre
le contrôle de la capitale régionale
mais kelly mais cette intervention
s'accompagne de nombreuses violences
contre les civils voire de crimes de
guerre pour certains amnesty
international accuse ainsi les troupes
impliquées d'avoir violé des centaines
de femmes et filles imposant à certaines
victimes esclavage sexuel et mutilations
les forces gouvernementales et les
milices ont commis des attaques
systématiques contre les femmes et les
filles y compris donc les mineurs dès
les premiers jours de leur arrivée aux
tigres et tout au long du conflit ce
sont des viols de masse cela signifie
que les femmes sont violées par
plusieurs hommes du rang leurs jours
certaines sont retenus comme esclave
sexuelle pendant des semaines pendant
lesquelles elles sont violées chaque
jour un conflit qui s'enlise pendant des
mois en juin 2021 dans un spectaculaire
retournement de situation les rebelles
reprennent mais qu'elle est et d'autres
territoires à la suite d'une contre
offensive d'ampleur et plf affirme que
la lutte va s'intensifier jusqu'au
départ des ennemis de la région malgré
un cessez-le-feu décrété par le
gouvernement l'onu s'alarme alors sur la
situation humanitaire catastrophique au
sein du pays selon les nations unies
plus de quatre cent mille personnes ont
franchi le seuil de famine au tigré
durant cet été la région reste sous un
blocus de facto de l'aide humanitaire ou
l'accès pour acheminer une aide
humanitaire vitale continue d'être
extrêmement restreint sans la
possibilité d'apporter des quantités
suffisantes et importante de fournitures
humanitaires d'argent et de carburant la
situation humanitaire dans le nord de
l'ethiopie va s'aggraver
considérablement en particulier dans la
région du tigré notre acteur participe à
ce drame humanitaire notamment
l'erythrée ce pays qui jouxte le tigre
et est allié aux forces gouvernementales
éthiopiennes dans ce conflit
l'intervention de l'armée érythréenne
l'umq tornier par le premier ministre
éthiopien a été accompagnée d' atrocités
imputées à ses soldats l'onu comme
amnesty international constate
aujourd'hui des crimes de guerre en
ethiopie un rapport cinglant rendu
public cette semaine le lendemain la
déclaration de l'état d'urgence sur tout
le territoire national elles accusent
toutes les parties nous avons des motifs
raisonnables pour croire que durant
cette période toutes les parties
impliquées dans les conflits du tigre et
ont commis des violations du droit
international des droits de l'homme du
droit humanitaire et du droit des
réfugiés
certaines de ces violations peuvent être
assimilées à des crimes de guerre et à
des crimes contre l'humanité les civils
du tigre et ont été soumis à des
violences et des souffrances brutale à
l'heure actuelle les conclusions de ce
rapport ne permettent pas de servir de
base à une action en justice mais
interpelle sur le drame qui se déroule
sous les yeux du monde et qui ne trouve
pour le moment aucune issue